normally cheaters reach speeds of up to
110 kilometers an hour here they barely
break a sweat but then here they're only
chasing a toy in the wild even then they
won't necessarily run every day if they
get a springbok they eat all of a good
solid meal they might not hunt until
four or five days later if they have
their choice there will be a sleep on 16
to 18 hours a day it's a natural
instinct for them unless there's a very
very good reason to run which is why we
say we offer them the opportunity to run
and it's a decision as you can see
whether they choose to run or not
Romeo you've been fed already dawn
Glover is manager a cheetah outreach in
Cape Town the center homes 11 cheetahs
they were all born in captivity the
center brings the cats from ethical
breeding programs where they're hand
raised
Sammy gee look at you gorgeous but it
means they've never learned to hunt
instead they serve as ambassadors for
their wild relatives
it gives visitors the chance to build a
bond with the Predators
well cheetahs especially their
non-aggressive they're running on a
fighter and for us to show that you can
have this amazing relationship and bond
with a with a wild predator and if they
can learn to trust us and live in
harmony with us we should be able to be
able to share the same emotional
maturity and learn how to live with them
as well in the wild there are natural
enemies but Anatolian guarding dog
Juliet and cheetah Romeo have been
brought up together here they are the
furry faces of a project being funded by
the Cape Town Centre to protect wild
cheetah cheetah numbers have fallen
drastically in just over a century from
around a hundred thousand to just over
seven thousand one hundred one of the
biggest threats to the cats are farmers
gotta be to Neogene almost 2,000
kilometers away farmer mone brahma
prepares to release his flock for the
day it's not always been easy letting
them roam in the past animals have been
lost the area chose us which is quite
difficult to farming we've got cheetah
we've got a lion coming through
occasionally leopard caracal jackal
there's those numerous predators in this
area many farmers use lethal methods
shooting predators or using poison to
protect their livestock but Brahma was
offered another choice cheetah Outreach
gave him his dog now she goes out with
the goats it's definitely a benefit to
not have to go out and kill certain
animals to protect your your income your
bread and butter
so yeah seeing the cheetah the leopard
in the natural environment is lovely not
having to go out with a gun and
prosecute them
unlike most big predators cheetahs hunt
during the day and so are blamed for
much of the lost livestock the guarding
dog program was designed to try to
combat the problem
on his farm Brahmas wife Rosamund runs
the dog breeding center project manager
Deon cilia's has come to see how the
dogs are doing the program provides
farmers with a dog for free and pays for
its upkeep for one year now there's even
a waiting list for the animals the
Anatolian Shepherd is quite a huge dog
he's quite bold and he stands back from
nothing they are not attack dogs they
are not aggressive at all and they would
just start barking when a predator is
around and usually that's enough
just keep predators away almost two
hundred and fifty dogs have been placed
with farmers in northern South Africa
Anatolian guarding dogs first have to be
integrated as puppies with their flock
from then on that they are fiercely
protective in a situation where there's
been a lot of rain for example
the goats might stay out and then we've
had times where the dogs will always
stay out with them they never leave them
even if they're hungry they they don't
they won't come back they stay out with
the goats come no matter what yes
back in Cape Town schools often visit to
learn about the organization's
activities and the dog project a swarthy
Allah can't see Lisa obviously education
plays a big role in the work of cheetah
outreach children are also able to learn
about some of South Africa's other
native species like this jackal
and most children in this part of South
Africa will never get to see a cheetah
in the wild the cats can be found in the
northern provinces but not this far
south for these children it's a big
moment the chance to actually touch one
of these predators a keeper keeps the
cheetah relaxed as they get close and
cheetah outreach gets exactly the kind
of emotion it hopes for Mike attitude
though the organization needs this kind
of attention to get financial support to
carry on with its work in Cape Town and
it's conservation project in the north
then being in captivity is a very
important role to play in terms of the
preservation of the wild cousins through
the awareness the education conservation
of a genetic pool of cheetahs because
there are so few of them left in the
world the big cats were already recorded
as vulnerable on the IUCN Red List and
for a species coming ever closer to the
brink
while cheetahs need all the help they
can get to ensure they have a future in
South Africa and beyond